Speaker 1: We know that Republicans are going
to be taking over the House of Representatives
at the start of 2023. And so that means that
for Democrats, there's not too many working
days remaining on the congressional calendar
to get the things that you want to get passed,
passed. And it means that these next few weeks
we have to be all hands on deck to get these
pieces of legislation through and get them
signed into law. Luckily, we'll still have
the Senate after the start of 2023, but we're
not going have the House anymore. And really
these opportunities where you have full control
of government, the House, Senate and presidency
don't happen too often. And so you have to make
the best of the time where you have it all. We
have a few more weeks and so it's time to get
busy. My hope is that with this added sense of
urgency, we'll be able to get the votes we need on
some of these things. And also, you don't have to
worry as much about some of these more vulnerable
senators and congresspeople because they don't
have to worry about an election for another couple
of years at least. So maybe you'll have more votes
post midterms than you had pre midterms. Chuck
Schumer is saying about this lame duck period, we
are going to try to have as productive a lame duck
session as possible. It's going to be heavy work,
long hours to try and get something done. Let's
hope he can deliver on this. I anticipate that
he's going to run into many of the same issues
that we've had over these past couple of years,
which is that you can't always get everyone on the
exact same page because you have slim majorities
to work with in the House and Senate. Now, in
these next few weeks, there are some must do's
in the agenda, some things that Democrats actually
absolutely have to get done. Like, for example,
they're going to need to pass legislation to keep
the government open and funded in order to avoid a
government shutdown. They also have to pass the
National Defense Authorization Act. That has to
get passed so that the military can get funded.
And you better bet that we're going to be able to
find the money to do that, because that is always
a top priority in Washington. There's also this
back and forth about raising the debt limit from
its current $31.4 trillion cap. Republicans may
try to hold this hostage in exchange for some
concessions on spending cuts. To be honest,
the debt ceiling talk and the government shutdown
talk, it doesn't interest me that much because
these things happen like every couple of years,
maybe even more frequently than that. And it's
always the same discussion. We always know that
they're going to do the right thing to keep the
government open and so that we won't default
on our debt and all these different things. But
it's just this big charade that comes up. I'm more
focused on the policy items that Democrats can get
done in these next couple of weeks. Like, for one,
they still have to codify interracial marriage
and same sex marriage. They had that preliminary
vote on the topic and 12 Republicans in the Senate
crossed over and voted along with the Democrats.
But they still need to pass this thing one more
time in the Senate. Hopefully that's a shoe in my
sense, is that it is in terms of other priorities.
They have to pass some legislation to clarify the
Electoral Count Act of 1887, which became a point
of interest when Trump was trying to overturn the
2020 election results. Democrats want to clarify.
The vice president's role is purely ceremonial
when they count the electoral votes. Of course,
it was believed for many, many years to
be ceremonial. But then Trump decided to
torpedo democracy and argued that Pence was
able to overturn the election in his favor.
And so Democrats want to make the text very much
clear on how you count electoral votes so that a
vice president can't just turn things over so
that they win. This is what Trump interpreted
to be a vindication, by the way, because he was
trying to claim that the whole time Mike Pence
had the authority to do this, and the fact that
Democrats are changing the law now means that he
was right, that Pence could have done this, and it
doesn't really make any sense. But anyway, they're
trying to do that. They're also looking at getting
more aid approved for Ukraine, especially with the
expectation that Kevin McCarthy is not going to
be amenable to approving more aid funding for
Ukraine once the Republicans take over. There's
contingents on the right, these noninterventionist
types, also these people who think that we
shouldn't help Ukraine at all in their fight
against the Russian invasion for one reason or
another, because they're okay with Putin's regime,
they're not going to want to see aid going
towards Ukraine. So that's another thing that
Democrats can try to do one last ditch effort on
that. They're also trying to get protections for
Dreamers with these final few weeks undocumented
immigrants who are brought to the U.S. as minors,
even though they didn't make the decision on their
own to come here, they still have to deal with,
you know, potential deportation, potentially
going back to a country that they never knew
because they weren't born here in the United
States and aren't technically citizens. So
that's another thing that Biden should try to do
in these next few weeks. I think that personally,
if you're going to go pedal to the metal on any of
these issues, it should probably be the dreamers
because it's perhaps the most consequential.
Like the same sex marriage thing, an interracial
marriage bill that'll probably get done pretty
easily. I'm also assuming we're going to be able
to keep the government funded and, you know, raise
the. Debt ceiling and all of those procedural
types of things. But in terms of what you can
actually do to make a material difference for the
public and how you can sort of increase Democratic
poll numbers and just do the most good with the
time that you have left. I think that protecting
the Dreamers should be a high priority. I wish
that there could be more things on this list.
But, you know, we've known since the start of
this Congress, the start of this presidency, that
we were not going to be able to get done all the
progressive wish list items that we wanted to get
accomplished done because we just were never going
to have the votes. We weren't able to repeal the
filibuster and all this stuff. But that doesn't
mean that you can't grab all these low hanging
fruit. That's what we've been trying to do over
these past couple of years, and hopefully with
these final weeks, we'll be able to do more of it.